and we're live
we are officially live so are we just
live now we are live episode number 65.
with adam and zenner welcome back
gang uh for those of you that are on
we're excited about today's podcast keep
in mind that we're going to do it for
today and thursday and then next week
we're gone for
a special project i was at a dealership
yesterday with uh dylan
so me dylan and mario go to this ferrari
dealership i'm looking at a couple cars
so mario you're saying we're looking at
the cars all the time we go in
a guy looks at me yeah he says uh hey
man
a little you know little italian guy
hey man walking around like he owns the
entire dealership he says
i just want you to know i never miss
your interviews i said oh really cool
that's cool man
i said which one ah only one kind it's
the mob interviews that's the only one i
watch i said yeah
which ones have you watched which ones
have i watched i watch all the mob
interviews
that's great that's that's cool you
watch all the mob interviews yeah he
said so what's the next thing you're
working on what's the next mob i said
i said i just want to let you know man
we may
potentially we may potentially do
something that could be the biggest
project we've ever worked on that could
be a history making type of a thing and
when i tell you this
it could truly be a history making type
of thing very complex very
complicated every day we're having
issues with seeing if this could happen
or not
not telling you it's going to happen but
if it does happen i'm going to make a
prediction
it could get 100 million views within
24. that's amazing is your life in
danger by doing this
it's it's always in danger every day
it's always in danger he asked me a very
interesting question he says
can i ask you a question i said yeah
sure why do these guys all trust you
like what do you mean why do they trust
you are you in the life i'm not in the
life man i'm just an insurance guy
entrepreneur
what a lucky day for him though the the
the person he follows most on youtube
walks in with a big budget that's that's
that's good for sales yes it's a good
day for them but we had a we had a good
conversation
uh dylan dylan's like i want to sit in
it and the guy
renee ended up driving the car with
dylan going you know god knows how
you know he was having a blast anyways
we had a good time yesterday with that
so are you potentially looking to get a
ferrari
i'm potentially looking to get it for a
guy make you a good deal
did he make you an offer you can't
refuse no he did not make me an offer i
couldn't refuse but uh we'll see what's
going to i have a 24-hour rule if i'm
going to make any kind of a big purchase
i sit on it you should have told them
you should have told him you're
connected because he might be a little
afraid now
he may have gotten me a little bit
bigger of a discount but we'll see
what's going to happen with that okay
let me remind you guys a couple things
number one
we asked for a uh uh what do you call a
logo which at the end of the podcast
we're going to show all the logos that
were sent to us if you haven't sent
yours
sick tweet it out at patrickbetdavid
with hashtag pbd
podcast we are looking at different i
don't know if we're going to take it or
not today
and finalize it but we're definitely
going to look at some uh uh what do you
call it some uh
logos today also if you're on the last
couple podcasts what we've been doing is
we've been picking and choosing certain
super chats
and we've been given ten times back so
if you put ten bucks we give you a
hundred dollars back if you give us five
bucks
if we like it we give you fifty dollars
back a guy steve give 10 100
he got a thousand dollars back so who
knows what we're going to do with the
super chat there's another lady that
gave
20 bucks and she got 20 times back yeah
you liked your story you gave her 20
so you know it depends on the story
question anything that we like about
what you say
we make why are we doing this what's the
reason let them know why i think i think
we're just doing it we want to get more
activity we want to get people to be
engaged we want people to get more
involved and we want to get this thing
to 100 000 subscribers and eventually a
million we feel there's a need today
for podcasts where opposing views are
being talked about and people get a
chance to make up their minds
you agree disagree great let's have a
discourse together and see what we can
think if you think you've got a good
point
put your money where your mouth is
literally we may even call some money
and we'll we'll call you out on it if
it's that good of a comment put some
money where your mouth
may even call you and have you get on
the podcast here with us like we did
with stephen and us a couple weeks that
was great
anyway we got a lot of stuff going on
okay first of all the the one thing that
to me
since it's i know a lot of people don't
want to talk about sports it's like the
last thing people want to talk about but
we got to talk about what just happened
this weekend with
fans going in westbrook being thrown
popcorn on you got kyrie irving having a
bottle being thrown yesterday at the
wizards game a guy runs into the
tray young spit on trey young got spit
on at a
next game a lot of this stuff that's
happening right so
yeah i'll read the story here to you i
don't know if we have it or not with the
kyrie which page is it on i'll re okay
page numbers okay page number four i'll
read the kyrie story but it's not just
kyrie there's quite a few of them that
we can get into
celtics fans suspected of throwing
bottle at kyrie irving charged with
assault and battery first of all
suspected
it's on camera it's not suspected we saw
a new york post
the knucklehead fan accused of hurling
water bottle at netstar
kyrie irving after sunday's playoff game
against the boston celtics
will be arraigned tuesday on one count
of assault and battery with a dangerous
weapon according to multiple reports
boston police said 21 year old cole
buckley
of uh braintree massachusetts was
arrested at td garden after a witness
reported
he threw a dasani water bottle that
gazed the head of irving it's
unfortunate that sports has come this
kind of crossroads irving said
where you are seeing old ways come up
underlying racism and treating people
like they are human zoo
uh in a human zoo kevin durant at it
have some respect for the game have some
respect for human beings
have some respect for yourself your
mother wouldn't be proud of you throwing
the water
at basketball players grow the f up and
enjoy the game it's bigger than you
sunday's instance was not the first
involving a fan during the playoffs a
fan was banned from the madison square
garden last week for spitting
at hawks guard trey young in game two of
the next game
and the wizards regard guard russell you
know we talk about popcorn so what are
your thoughts about all this stuff
taking place you know
just because they're preaching about it
doesn't mean it's gonna go away i was
listening to the kevin durant quotes and
they
act like their their voice is gonna make
a difference yeah there's x amount of
idiots out there that they don't give a
damn this has been going on for a week
now where it's been a big deal and it
happened last night
someone stormed the court and you know
he was answering a dare
right he was drunk you could just see
that he was laughing by the time he got
onto the court
he knew he was going to be arrested
kyrie irving that's it did you guys
think the water bottle was full i saw
the video of it
i couldn't tell if that thing flying
through the air was half a good question
i
i think it was by the way it has to have
water water it has to have weight in it
yeah so what kyrie irving did first
though is he wiped his feet on the logo
not that that
warrants you know almost to be getting
clocked by a water bottle but you know
celtics fans are nuts i used to live in
boston i used to be the sports anchor at
fox in boston so i've been in the middle
of this i'll tell you fans are crazy
i'll tell you one story the the patriots
were playing the vikings one game
and there was a fan from minnesota that
went there and the viking fans you know
sometimes they wear those hats
that have the long horns kind of that
nordic thing it's just a thing they wear
so this guy felt something tugging on
the back of his head so he reaches back
there to stop and the dude behind him
had a scissors and was cutting the
ponytail off
okay of the fake hat now here's the
problem the guy that was the vikings fan
was a world-class surgeon
this guy went through his tendons on his
finger and he was serious he was his
like surgery career was about over
so weird things have happened in the
stands no that really really totally
happened
unbelievable yeah so this stuff does go
on now here's the problem
the nba players kyrie irving is the last
one you want to have this happen to
because he's going to talk about it
every single day he's going to turn it
into this huge thing where every nba
player
has a target on them and they really
don't these things are being blown out
of proportion a little bit
because they've been happening one after
another after another but you know
they did the right thing by arresting
this guy i think to prove a point so
this dude is gonna be in serious trouble
i would say that would be the only way
to slow this thing down but there is a
very very small percentage of people
that are so stupid so idiotic and so
brazen that it will continue to happen
just because they don't care
so yeah good point the the um by the way
if you're watching this i'm curious
comment below what you what you think
about what's taking place
do you have a unique opposing view or
anything else on what happened with the
nba
and all these fans that are upset with
them go ahead adam so they're clearly
going to make an example out of this guy
in boston
i mean they're they're they're charging
him with throwing a dangerous
weapon it was a water bottle here right
so do you think that's the right move to
choice
they're making an example sure so i mean
salt and battery yeah but do you think
that's a good idea i think they
do i think that throwing a water bottle
at somebody is a dangerous weapon i
think no it's a good idea that they're
yes they are making an example of them
they're basically saying if you're going
to do this kind of crap
be prepared to pay the yes i do um
but it is a slippery slope right now you
threw popcorn on somebody now you're
getting arrested for a popcorn
uh i think by far and away the worst
thing that happened was someone
spit on trey young keep in mind we're
still living in covid you know times
right now that's absolutely ridiculous
to me what do you mean you're spitting
on a plane and the guy the guy just gets
banned from a knicks game yeah and he's
the mo one of the most likeable players
in the nba what are you doing
what are you doing spinning on a player
what are you doing on anybody yeah
so i'm sorry go ahead but it's almost
like people
haven't been out for a year and they
forget how to act because that's
literally what happened here
but i think a a bigger
story here is that when you think
nobody's watching you think you can act
tough
it's sort of the drake's famous line
uh trigger fingers turn to twitter
fingers it's sort of like yours keyboard
warriors
and if you're in the masses and oh no
one's gonna see it let me just talk [ __ ]
let me spit on somebody let me throw a
water bottle no one's gonna see it
but the problem is that you're
forgetting is there's cameras everywhere
everything you do on social media
everything you do period
is going to get caught so uh charles
barkley had a pretty good recommendation
he goes
this punk ass take him down to the
locker room and let him have a
one-on-one conversation with kyrie
let me know what happens to this guy in
boston right so that's obviously charles
barkey
the the other side uh of the coin here
is that
talk about level of pettiness is how
petty can we go here because
kyrie obviously he'll turn anything into
a racial issue none of this to me
is anything racial whatsoever these are
just idiot fans doing
idiot things with indian idiot
tendencies but
now the celtics fan base have started a
petition
talk about pettiness to charge
kyrie with aggravated assault because in
he threw a basketball into the stands
when he was upset he threw a ball
so now you know how many time fans do
you think that's good
phenomenal to throw to
let me tell you um it's sun it's monday
when do we do
jennifer's baby shower what's this
monday we did a sunday okay we're at the
house
okay everybody's up there you know
you're you're trying to change the
diaper which we realized if you haven't
seen i mean
if we pull up adam's video do you have
adam's video with adam try to uh
to put the clothes on of this kid if you
don't have it do you have he can pull it
up
for hire to change yeah he's not but you
know but here's the thing what i liked
about it is you were so proud of
yourself
i thought i did it you had a moment
where you're like mario what do you mean
mario beat me i'm done
and it's like the kid was just not
rapping you know the buttons on the
bottom you got to put by the diapers he
didn't put that up i would imagine he
mummified the baby
right i mean she could have seen like
somebody taping an ankle it was a proud
it's like nick young when he shot it he
turned around he held the three up
as if he made it and didn't go on that
was that he just kind of held the three
i learned
i learned when changing a baby it's uh
with a as an adult do you put if you're
if you put your underwear on first
that's first right
you put your pants on or your shirt on
first what do you do well for the baby
you get no no no no no no no for you oh
but this is a pants owner's shirt as a
baby buddy i'm not talking about let me
you want to talk about it baby let me
make sure you're saying with the baby
you put the shirt on first then the
pants aren't like
i did i had a bag already have a baby so
we can get trained on this
i'm working on it all right so let me
get a lot of practice let me let me let
me give you this part here on what
happened so
we're smack talking everybody's talking
trash to each other okay when you talk
trash what happens you just have to be
ready okay when you talk and trust so
dylan starts talking trash to rock yeah
yellow my son he's like i pick you know
such and such to beat rock
donnie the baby laundry
folding competition so afterwards rob
wins
and rob looks at dylan he says so you
picked donny to beat me huh i won
and he says give me one of these and
dylan didn't no
he reacted very negatively furious it's
like i'm not giving
he just sat down the corner i said come
here i gotta tell you he had that look
on his face so that's coming i gotta
talk to you so he comes and sits next to
me
and i'm whispering to him here's what i
told him i said listen dylan here's how
life works
okay if you don't want people to talk
trash to you
don't talk trash if you don't want
people to take shots at you don't take
shots
if you don't want people to really kill
you don't really kill them
if you don't want if you don't want that
don't say anything right but the moment
you do
you have to be ready to know that that
person could say something back to you
and if you do you have a couple choices
try to say nothing or you go back and it
could go back and forth constantly but
that's a choice you got to make i said
on one end
i'm glad you're not afraid but on the
second hand i got i want you to be ready
that this can happen
what's the moral of the story kyrie
irving is dylan
that's simple kyrie irving is dylan he's
a baby
is what he is ever the question that
nobody's asking yesterday espn posted
something i wish i could go on my
instagram to take a look at this
kyrie irving is a seven-year-old boy
right now okay
i posted on instagram when the picture
when they posted a picture of all the
people that i ran into the floor spit or
done everything right posted a question
i said
uh all of this is pathetic but can we
ask the one question
why are fans so upset at nba players why
or is that an off-limit question
and then boom it went off with
commentary
yo let me guess you're going to say it's
covet it's this it's not it's not that
big of a deal
it is that big of a deal here's why why
are the fans upset
why are they doing this why is it all of
a sudden let me get this straight
you can go for a team that you played
who paid you
you can go take your shoes and smear
your shoe on the leprechaun
after you won the game assuming no one's
going to see it
what the hell you think is going to
happen these are kids that
you did not see this he goes at the end
of the game so imagine this is the
celtics logo with the leprechaun the
leprechaun
he puts his shoe down and he goes like
this on the leprechaun
kind of like when tyrell star leprechaun
then you have this 21 year old kid who
probably grew up watching the celtics
with his dad
and his mom screaming at the screen
being a doc cause you know how celtics
fans are
die hard he's gonna take it personal
there's a part of me
that i like a fan defending what he
stands for to the point of throwing a
water bottle absolutely not that's not
acceptable
but listen kyrie why are they upset at
you maybe you've been rubbing it in
their face for the last 12 months that
everybody out there that disagrees with
you is racist and they're sick of it
they're just absolutely sick of your
unnecessary comments that you're making
and you
are sitting here acting like you don't
understand you know i'm just
life is tough you know it's really tough
right now and you know i'm just
you know i have to deal with certain
things i'm going to go away and play not
play a few games and the team has to pay
20 million bucks every year nobody knows
where the hell even duran says i don't
know where you are
oh but you can go out there and smear on
the thing i don't know about that now on
the westbrook side
here's one thing about westbrook
westbrook plays hard and i don't like
what happened that one time when the
guys were flipping them off when he was
you know you know
by the sidelines when i don't know this
was like four years ago okay we'll get
into it with fans
all the time i'm a westbrook fan and i
think westbrook is a dog and i think the
league
unfortunately is not gonna have a lot of
guys like that he's one of a kind he's
in a league of his own with the people
that are fighting well he just broke the
triple double
record the question is why are people
upset you know what happened with kwame
brown this last weekend i don't know if
you guys have been following the last
two weeks what's going on
what do you think about what's going on
with kwame what do you think about
what's going on he posted something on
social media what exactly did he say i
forgot the
number one pick he called out stephen a
he called that charlemagne god he called
that
stephen jackson he called out everybody
yeah i remember reading that thing yeah
he wasn't very articulate
on matt barnes yeah yeah he has no
credibility who doesn't
well let me tell you what he did say
which i like i tell you what he did says
which i like so
he went out there and he said uh about
the fact that
hey just because i posted something and
i said look at this candace brown uh uh
video
what are your thoughts about it
everybody thinks i'm racist i'm just
watching the candace brown video
candace owens candice on this video
right i'm watching the candace owns and
what she has to say and
people are calling me who are you voting
for i'm voting for trump oh you're not
voting for biden what are you talking
about and i said give me his policies
which policies are you voting for biden
this guy's going that direction so then
he's saying for the last 13 years he
says
you guys are out there bashing me says
stephen a i was a 17 year old kid
working under michael jordan who was
talking trash to me 24 7.
i don't know how to handle seven you
know at 17 years old how to be having
somebody like that that's constantly
berating me right
kwame is pushing the envelope hardcore
steven a smith makes a response video oh
i saw that i don't know if you saw that
one
of course did you see the results on the
bottom though how many likes and
dislikes it got
i did not have you seen that kai can you
pull up that video on steven a smith
well he went in on kwame bryant
smith did not let anything i i know he
no joe's bar
go to go to youtube just go to youtube
and type in steven a kwame brown
steven a smith club that's fine kwame is
with the k
i think it's uh kw k-w k-w
k-w there you go just talking about it
just go down right there top there you
go
uh click on the first one but here's
what you gotta do you gotta do it in a
way where
[ __ ] it's going to play it's going to be
ah you can't play it so here's what i
want you to do okay we can't do that
go and look at it yourself uh kai look
at it yourself on your phone and tell us
how many likes and dislikes it has
kwame brown responds to espn i want you
to tell me how many likes and dislikes
steven a's
video has i don't know if you can do
that if you can't do that i'll do it
myself
yeah that's the only data i want he's
going to regret that video who is steven
a tell me why because
he's paid to be a commentator and you
have opinions never played tell us can
you say it on the mic so everybody can
hear you
yeah are we good yeah we can hear you
going uh so the video has
28 000 likes and 30 000 dislikes
28 000 likes and 30 000 dislikes which
means
most people didn't like what he had to
say if it was an election the dislikes
wins the election
okay on the video that's not the case
with stephen a you so they're basically
they're saying that he thinks he should
not have said it no
because because the point is here's a
kid that came at 17 years old
you're expecting a 17 year old kid to
have all this pressure yesterday i got a
call from one of our guys
and we're having a conversation about
somebody that was dealing with anxiety
and pressure and blood pressure went up
right which is a real thing by the way
which is a real thing by the way
you're seeing what happened with the uh
uh
osaka you know dealing with the
pressures of the media all this other
stuff and you know how that handles this
is one of the reasons why you're gonna
have so much respect
for folks who run for office in their
70s you're talking about
clinton obama not obama trump
biden sanders these people are in their
60s 70s running with all the pressure
nonstop trash talking about you your
wife your kids your
i mean it's tough your husband
constantly they're built for that though
they've been doing it
it's not about their build for that at
17 you maybe not
and kwame had to go through that at 17.
he was destroyed at 17 years old
here's a kid that played in the league
for 13 years made 65 million dollars you
tell me any human being that plays
has a job for 13 years makes 65 million
dollars
and you trash them for having 13 years
65 million dollars of money you make
and they went after the guy so finally
he just pushed back he snapped everybody
good for him yeah his podcast was
blowing up by the way with kwame brown
he grew up in the sticks i mean he was
not
exactly a mature young man not a guy
yeah that
yeah and imagine michael jordan the
pressure he was putting on that kid
because michael wanted to prove himself
as an owner
as a guy running the team because
frankly you know michael jordan
basically failed as an owner and as a gm
so far i think you could make that
argument so
you know he put his reputation on the
line by drafting kwame brown but
stephen a um i think maybe you know he
might regret that a little but he has no
choice
right he can't he works for disney he
has to turn this into
something where kwame has to be wrong
because
everything with them is a black and
white issue literally especially in the
nba right now and as far as kyrie irving
no chance that they winning the nba
championship because of him
zero even though they have most talent
they're not going to win because of him
the only guy that could get him to play
to his potential is lebron right and
tell me why no way they can win it
because of him because his mind
is not set on being a champion right now
he is set on being a victim
and looking up the next thing that he
can complain about and realizing how bad
his life is
and he's got the security of the
contract and he's already won a title
i don't know if i go that far i'll go as
far as saying he's a terrible uh
uh player to represent your brand like i
wouldn't want him
representing a brand but i think i ad
just got hurt sons are not going to beat
him you know
utah it's not going to happen who else
you got under philadelphia joe
you know what's coming out of the easter
egg well philadelphia
he got hurt what's his name embiid got
hurt you got milwaukee i mean i just
don't see it i think durant is that good
of a player
but but to go back to this to go back to
this this issue here that we're talking
about
um what the nba did last year
what the industry of comedy has done for
the last decade
what hollywood has done the last 30
years
what these what tech has done the last
decade
they're gonna pay a price for this i was
on an instagram live with
jordan belfor you know wolf of wall
street and he was sharing his
frustration i can't understand what's
going on you know i don't even have a
voice if i say something just because
i'm not
you know a democrat and i have an
opposing view they're coming after me
and they're sending all this
i said that's a jordan that's not how
life works cause what do you mean
i said you can't bully people for too
long
you just cannot do it hollywood's
bullied people yes and guess what
mistakes they've made you know who runs
hollywood
you know what people don't realize who
runs hollywood what what what ethnicity
what
chinese yes and jewish and jewish
of course do you realize how jews are
being treated right now in america
do you realize if the jewish community
flips
what happens if the top five producers
in hollywood who are jewish flip to the
other side what happens all of a sudden
what are they going to say all of a
sudden do you know what happened to
comedy
comedy if you make fun of trump you have
a job if you make fun of biden god
forbid you don't have a job
comedy is all about on one side right
now it's not both sides i want to hear
both sides of comedy
i want to see somebody make fun of both
sides comedy you can't get up there and
talk about all the stuff that the left
is doing because god forbid if you call
them
out you're being seen yeah and the same
thing's happening with the nba
and mlb has almost fallen forward with
manfred with what he's doing
but if nba's wondering why people are
pissed off at you
you disrespected half of america you
made half of america feel guilty for
crime
they never committed you know how
ridiculous it is to be with somebody
that constantly makes you feel guilt for
something you never did
imagine you're dating somebody that
constantly blames you for something
you've never done right how long can you
tolerate that
not very long that's what the mvp is
doing exactly and i'm sorry i'm sorry
kyrie
i i watched this guy play he's
ridiculous
you know that pepsi commercial with with
kyrie who comes in he dresses like the
old man in the movie
uncle drew dude you don't even know how
much i love this guy's game
you have no idea how much i love this
guy's game but you have divided america
and what you're getting i am what what
you're getting right now
it's not as bad as you think it's gonna
get but here's the part
when a year ago people were saying why
are so many people protesting and
writing
well why do you think they're writing
maybe the black community is upset
you're right maybe they are upset
i give them credence why they're upset
now to go and loot and destroy
businesses
no i'm not okay with that but when the
shoe flips and i were given the other
side
why do you think people on the other
side upset at you
do you think they've run the numbers and
realize what's gonna happen when some of
the money isn't flowing into the nba
anymore because that will happen very
shortly if it hasn't already and by the
way i like
why kyrie i liked him wiping his feet on
the logo i thought that was kind of
a little fu to the crowd whatever he
used to play their little
banter but then you can't have that
reaction when someone gets upset that
you did it but i thought it was kind of
funny he's kind of subtly just you know
but it's okay if you do that i don't
care if you do that just be ready yeah
be ready if you do that if you hustle
off the court then
you know if that happens don't be upset
if a
prideful proud fan of the celtics
retaliate
who's a 21 year old knucklehead don't be
surprised right okay
and drunk at the end of the day you
cannot do that to folks who are data so
now
if if if the mba here's all here's all
i'm curious about we're going to go to
the next topic i'm sure some of you guys
that are listening to this you're like
you know but this isn't sports
this is this isn't sports this is but
it's it's sports impact on society
it's it's go ahead no i'm just saying
this this is this is pop culture here's
what i'm curious about adam this is what
i'm curious about tom
all i'm watching right now is to see how
adam silver responds
because that dictates the rest when the
nfl got
really ugly in 2017 is because of how
roger goodell responded to what
colin kaepernick i am so curious to know
how silver responds to this and you've
been very clear on on what
uh goodell should have done he should
have called kaepernick into his office
he said look
person's upset give him a damn call what
are you upset about pretending that it
was just going to go away it was not the
same what are you upset about
let's have a conversation what
frustrates you
let's get to it let's address it and
then we move on yeah
not not this whole thing that's taking
place right now i think you could make
the argument though that
adam silver is the second most powerful
person in the nba behind lebron
i think lebron dictates so much of this
i mean i guarantee you
he is telling silver how to handle some
of these and he's involved in this in
some way or another
i'm sure of it i do agree with you on
the lebron uh
does sort of run the nba silver
obviously the commissioner he's there
i do disagree with you that there's a
zero percent chance that
uh there's a country in brooklyn not
happening dude they're they're actually
literally
literally the favorites to win the
championship with durant and hardin
now um and b just got hurt not to get
too basketball-y yeah but they are
literally the favorite so to say they
have a zero percent chance it's just
factually inadequate however the part
i'll give them credence to is
there are certain players that distract
you from the big goal
that create additional type of
distractions i don't mind you know how
sometimes uh coaches would go out there
and they would take the heat
but the heat would take pressure off the
players so players can just perform and
the coach would take the pressure
this is a different kind of pressure
this is unnecessary attention you bring
into the team
your team's becoming a target that's
what kyrie's doing not smart
he's bringing unnecessary attention just
by getting a water bottle thrown at him
like if yes
if he didn't know
no no you go smear the the logo i i'm
not a fan of that
well the the the back story to that is
not to get too kyried out here he's had
a
an emotional meltdown of the past few
years keep in mind he played for boston
he got ran out of town basically nba say
take a year off
no why doesn't the nba say take you why
would the nba want him to take a year
off why wouldn't you want him to take a
year off
why what well exactly i don't think the
nba is going to come in and say kyrie
yeah take it easy buddy he's got a
contract he's a general manager here's
what i'm going to say to him uh
you're under this much stress you're
under this much stress life is down
i think he literally took 20 games off
this year no no take an entire year
i don't think he's trying to take an
entire year because he wants the money
that's why well
everyone wants the money no but you want
the money without the freedom of having
to be responsible for the money that's
been paid to you
he got a responsibility so the fan that
bought a season ticket
of the nets what does he do the fan that
bought a forty thousand dollar court
side season to defend about a ten
thousand dollar season take it with his
kids
for forty one games thirty six years
there were no fans this year
uh for the majority what does that fan
do
what does that fan do who's saying this
guy's not playing
what does the fans do they want him to
play yeah but i mean they had durant
they didn't play half the season they
got hardened
there wasn't a team half the season he
hasn't played at the end of the day i
think they're just going to be
it's a playoff i think they're going to
do what they got to do in the playoffs
let's see so we'll see what's going to
happen by the way if you agree
if you agree we have 220 thumbs up right
now no thumbs down if you agree
with the idea of the fact that a lot of
this
is caused by them pissing people off
pissing fans up
put thumbs up if you absolutely disagree
and say pat i absolutely disagree with
what you're saying
put thumbs down i'm curious we got 220
to zero right now
i want to hear your thoughts on that
secondly i got a question for you guys
you know for some of you guys that
subscribe and you press that
notification button
do you get notified when our uh uh
podcast goes live i'm just curious to
know how youtube system is working out
if it is great if not do me a favor
folks
can you click on that subscribe and the
notification button so you're notified
every time we go live with these
podcasts let's continue
uh adam i'm going to go to your favorite
story today yeah southwest pilot
sentenced for watching porn mid-flight
committing lewd act okay very important
i asked adam and tom right before the
whole thing what is your favorite story
guess what adam said porn
that's his favorite story great let's
address it it's a catastrophe
he's a pilot southwest pilot sentence
for watching porn mid-flight committing
loot act new york post a southwest
airlines pilot who was watching porn
exposes generals to a female officer
on a flight to florida has been
sentenced for to one year probation
michael hock 60 apologized before u.s
magistrate
judge mark olson ordered him on friday
to serve
probation and pay five thousand dollar
fine the incident occurred on a flight
that was he was piloting from
philadelphia to orlando from august 10
2020 prosecutors
federal prosecutor said when the plane
reached cruising altitude hawk got out
of the pilot seat and disrobed
and began watching pornographic material
on a laptop computer on the cockpit
prosecutor said
haku retired shortly after the incident
was charged in april intentionally
committing the dude
indecent or obscene act in a public
place he pleaded guilty to all charges
adam since it's your story oh yes this
is my story well this uh certainly puts
uh
flying in the cockpit a little to the
perspective
that's good i mean yeah so this guy
maybe took that the cockpit thing too
literal
but you can't make this crap up and i pl
as i was reading the story i'm thinking
to myself
please tell me this wasn't in florida
please tell me if this wasn't in florida
flight goes from philly to orlando
florida ah
florida does it again florida man this
time it was actually the pilot in the
in the cockpit and then obviously right
after the story comes out
he's retired he's decided to retire he's
60 years old it's time for him to retire
and he's put out the pasture so uh talk
about
just the the definition of cancel
culture
the me too the meat shame on these guys
the metoo movie canceling a pilot
meaning pathetic meaning this is let the
man
let the man disrobe i mean
but this is everything
wrong everything that's wrong in america
right now was
literally done in this cockpit right
here the metoo movement the cancer
culture the
they all have a point here yeah and um
this is anything sensitive talk about
having your hand on a different joystick
as you're planning uh flying the plane
you know i don't find anything about
this story funny i mean even though it's
humorous this guy makes me sick
he really truly does i mean you are an
experienced pilot
with 150 souls as sully would say right
yeah
you're responsible i mean could you ima
i mean can you imagine a real pilot how
disgusted they
are by this i'm disgusted by everything
this creep i think he got off easy
i guarantee you i guarantee you this his
the pilot's union is going to put a
little cocoon around him and protect him
also if i'm a pilot i am so pissed off
at this guy because here's my reaction
you don't do [ __ ] when you fly a plane
it's all automated so you have time to
look at porn
all right that just goes to show that
everything is computerized and automated
you're not even flying this thing
the whole thing is so wack so weird and
to think that he only got supervised
probation or whatever he has and a five
thousand dollar fine
and then did you hear how he described
it uh here's the quote from southwest
uh another nothing to the left southwest
did investigate investigate the matter
and as a result
ceased paying mr hawk any benefits he
was entitled to as a result of his
separation from the airline but he says
it was like a simultaneous prank that he
was doing
i don't know too many other 60 year old
women that find that money
so anyway i think the guy's a perv i'm
just i'm just wondering what his other
fellow co-pilots have to say because
this
guy's been flying he's 60 years old he's
probably been flying for 30 years or so
and all these other pilots like oh
that's just hawk doing what hawk do
just exposing his genitals yeah i just i
just know
moving forward every time on a flight
i'm first class and i see
the pilot going to the bathroom all i'm
going to think about is i know what he's
doing right now yeah
here's the thing let me ask you a
question what if the story was different
what if the story was
flight attendant and pilot caught is
that different would you have judged it
differently
like they were basically on the cockpit
going on they were mile high club in it
what would you would you have said
salute to the
what would you have said would you
absolutely you know what i mean that's
why they call you the captain
i'm going to say you guys have so much
down time go do it in the hotel
i mean do it in the shuttle bus going
back and forth just because i found
their lives a mile
high up what do you mean what other time
do i gotta i gotta say something yeah
we're talking about the mile high
mile high club you ever you ever uh mile
high uh
these are two married men sitting at
yesterday's come on man you okay you
tell us
yeah i've attempted to it's just
i'd rather just you know dark plain in
your seat whatever but private is piece
of cake just so you know well yeah okay
but when you're when you're
private well you mean mandatory if the
door closes that is that is a good point
you just tell the pilot gentlemen can
you close that door
yeah i think the mile high club is a
little overrated the little gross little
bathroom people are waiting we
are knocking yeah i mean
you gotta get it done at one point in
your life but harmless
doing this yeah no no when the moment it
involves
exposing to another person like flight
attendant now you're just you know
you're
you're an idiot to do something like
this there's no difference between this
and some of these stories you hear about
some comedians went through
some athletes go through you're putting
yourself in a situation like that if
you're doing that it's a mistake
you got to think about it it was exposed
to a female officer i assume that's the
co-pilot is that what that means
yeah so she must have been the person
that ratted him out yeah
exactly so i want to get her perspective
on this you know who knows what happened
there who knows what happened all i can
say is if this
if this was two folks going at it in the
cockpit would you have judged it
differently well
do you think it's it might be happening
for all you know i already mentioned
i bet your pilots are sitting there
saying what is this guy talking about
like this is a story
what are you talking about this happens
every day we spend a lot of time on our
life
mile high where do you expect us to do
something in the hotel after that anyway
so adam i hope you're grateful for us
here and your favorite story so now that
we got that i needed to get that out of
my mind yeah that's great that's it now
everybody knows
you are part of the mile high club that
almost almost part of the mile high club
that couldn't get it done because the
bathroom was so small but he said it was
overrated
the bathrooms and every plane i go to
you know how i have to go i i'm like
this
exactly right now you're getting you got
to get two people in there not happening
no it's not going up it's a tough
situation midgets they'd be banging in
the in the bathroom
they do it literally they're doing their
little pieces
little people buddy okay let's keep
going let's keep going so u.s airlines
refunded 12.8 billion dollars of
travelers in 2020 12.8 billion dollars
this is a fox business story 11 u.s
airlines issued 12.84 billion dollars in
cash refunds to customers in 2020 as the
coronal virus pandemic
appended the travel industry and the
head of the industry trade group
airlines for america a4a said in a
letter to lawmakers on
friday kalio said the cash refunds which
counted for 20
of airlines revenue last year came on
top of billions of dollars of travel
credits
that are now being used as a rapid clip
to book
fresh flights the redemption of voucher
currently accounts for 10 or 15
carriers monthly ticket sales and is
expected to increase
in coming months as the pandemic winds
down and markets and
venues reopen thoughts no sympathy
whatsoever for the airlines
because hey they got 25 billion in
bailout money at the beginning of the
pandemic
they've always got their hand out
they're always getting taken care of
zero sympathy that's my first reaction
number one i don't believe them
i don't believe they gave back 12.8
billion dollars
so i'm just telling you right now
documented though that's going to be
like an audit if you say it doesn't
matter he doesn't believe it that's fine
let him have his opinion
maybe it could be fuzzy math it could be
mysterious account he's got a point you
get 25 billion dollars of bailout
yeah i fly a lot we all fly a lot yeah
you actually fly
i've never gotten money back from an
airline it's a credit on another flight
so if
if they're trying to disguise that as
giving money back meanwhile that money's
working for them you got to get morale
to make the calls
you got to make ball make the calls
you'll get you'll get more than credit
back but go ahead okay
that's true that's a good point right
you know i need to get out of here but
then i always know that there's another
flight coming so i might as well just
put it somewhere else
um so anyway that's my two reactions a
no sympathy whatsoever
b i don't believe you you don't believe
the math that's fine tom
are you saying there there isn't some
sort of distorted accounting principles
that could be happening
i'm not i'm not arguing with you i'm
just saying let the boy watch
let him do his thing i'm letting you do
your thing do you have any opinions yeah
i do i think actually
uh right when the pandemic happened i
had actually a bunch of flights that
were booked yeah
for march you know that in the insurance
conference everyone has their spring
meetings
in march and april i had spring meetings
galore and
being in miami the hub is american
american airlines so i had a lot of
flight spoke to american
actually got to give a shout out to
america and they were actually pretty
damn good
they reimbursed any flights they uh they
said that there's no uh
charges whatsoever for for changing
flights for cancer fights
all good they were actually pretty
decent but the one thing that that i
thought about
um with you know the bailout money
is the the speech that chamas had
chamath palapatiya had
at the beginning of the pandemic where
basically he said let him fail
let him fail and people were this was on
cnbc people were shocked what do you
mean let him fail he's like
if you he's right though yeah you know
that's part of capitalism is the freedom
to fail yeah so
if you took all your money that you
received from the trump tax breaks in
and you used it for stock buybacks and
you didn't use it to
make your company stronger or invest in
the people or whatever you needed to do
to make your business healthier and you
just use it for stock buybacks
you report you're so right so actually
when jamaat said that
that was actually the first time that
i've heard of him i was like what was
this guy talking about letting airplane
airlines fail what what what what he's a
smart and then it it kind of resonated
with me especially
with all the bailouts that happened yeah
uh since the pandemic what about you
here's what i would say about this i
think what airlines by the way just so
you know restaurants
the other day i saw an article by
bloomberg that said uh
actually instead of 50 of restaurants
going out of business only 14
of restaurants went permanently out of
business i'm like only yeah
14 percent of restaurants when i only
only 14
american population though it's only no
no no no what do you
listen but then they'll flip and they'll
say 2.6 million americans that so how
come you don't say only what do you mean
only 14 percent of restaurants
went out of business this is a bloomberg
remember of that 14
86 of the businesses that are
restaurants probably are hanging on by a
thread
there's no they have no other option i
mean it's a family thing so
just because they're not out of business
doesn't mean they're like surviving or
threatening margins are like this
margins make sense even smaller in
restaurants
way smaller margins are like this in
restaurants and margins are like this
and
exactly when they're airline airline
industries margins are like this
if i'm looking at this right now here's
what i'm thinking about
forget about the 12.8 billion dollars i
have to pay back to travelers forget
about the 25 billion dollars that they
got
for uh what do you call it the bailouts
forget about all that stuff
every single airline company out there
if the ceo is going to do anything right
right now here's what i'd be doing
i would have every single c-suite
executive mine in the company
read the book blue ocean strategy i'm
gonna have a conference column and say
guys
let me tell you where we are right now
we need to read two books
one is blue ocean strategy and the other
book is
uh let me give you the name it's the
story of apple kai what's not apple ibm
kai what's the apple uh
ibm book i had you read what is it
uh how elephant stands
i had this as my book for executives
last month that we went through
who says elephants can't dance can you
put that up there so people can't see it
i don't make money off this i don't know
who wrote i couldn't tell you the
author's name
but i had every single one of my
executives read this because the
recommendation was given to me by david
vega a new ceo that we hired the guy's a
flipping amazing guy and he said pat why
don't we read this book so we read the
book
it's how the ibm ceo came in and cleaned
house
okay every airline company
needs to read blue ocean strategy i
think is by wc chen
and they need to read this book uh who
says elephants can dance
because your bigger problem isn't covid
your bigger problem is the last 12
months changed people's behavior
and if this behavior stays forever you
are
screwed if this behavior doesn't change
forget about how much money you got
dealing here forget about all this
buyback stuff
you may be going out of business if you
don't change your current
business model business model is broken
today the way they're doing it they have
to figure out a different dude by the
way
the idea i would take for airlines is
the following here's an idea for you on
airlines
when you get on airlines what can you
buy
actually tell me what you can buy when
you get on airlines headset booze now
they're giving headsets for free or five
bucks okay okay
food there's little snacks what is
something snack packs uh freaking why
they get absorbed but you know what i
don't know how much the airlines make
for that right
but here's my question for you i'm sorry
why don't you
put additional things to buy like you
know these games that you get for free
and you buy
seven hundred dollars worth of stuff
that you know i'm in colombia with my
friend stephen awful
offers like look what steve's doing he
just keeps playing this game steve was
hooked to the game
spend a few thousand i'm like what are
you buying i said well i'm buying this
because i'm trying to do this and steve
was killing it in the game but
they got they got a guy to go from
getting a free game to spending seven
hundred dollars at that people are
spending five ten thousand dollars right
why don't airlines create upsells what
is an upsell
okay if i'm up there by myself
what things do i want or do i need think
about it airline industry
what would you like to spend money on
and put tears and the tiers could be
10 bucks 50 bucks 100 bucks 500 some
people would spend the money
you're up there like hey would you like
this great i don't know what it is
but they have to figure right away you
got 400 people on a flight
you mean to tell me you can't get 40
grand like make some money off these
undivided attention of an audience you
got stop just selling the credit cards
what other way can you make money off of
them oh yeah i love those credit cards
they have to start
figuring out better ways to uh make
money
off of the customers that yeah a
salesperson they have to start looking
at it this way
if a financial advisor morgan stanley
dean witter
was to be told hey every day i'm going
to give you
a hundred different audience to speak in
front of
and average audiences 400 people what
would that financial advisor say
it's freaking sick yeah that's insane
you're kidding me no
that's the airline industry how many
flights do you have a day
i don't know 100 200 500 a thousand
that's
100 200 500 000 people they can speak to
for 400 people on it
what if you do a sponsorship you bring
your morgan stanley dean with a guy that
gets five minutes to speak to everybody
and morgan pays you a hundred thousand
dollars for that wow that's a good
question
what if you bring what if you freaking
do something with this yeah that's a
ridiculous opportunity
i don't understand what the hell these
airline industries are doing they're
thinking this same
you know old-school method of running a
business is gonna work dude you're about
to go out of business
you better get your act together so two
books if they're listening by the way if
anybody's in the airline industry
or knows of somebody send this short
clip or segment to them so they can
listen to this because if not
i i want the airline industry to stay in
business
i want barnes and noble to stay in
business there's certain things i want
to stay in business but they need to get
creative but the airline industry is
going to stay in different
in business the industry with just some
airlines are going to go out of business
that's yeah
and that was i think jamaat's initial
point is some businesses are going to go
i just want you to get creative and
innovative that's great we win we win if
people get innovative and creative the
consumer wins you and i win i i'm going
to say this
you know some airlines just do it so
much better than others and it's so
obvious so
shout out to jetblue shout out to delta
you guys clearly get it you're very good
now i'm going to make another prediction
and as we know these aren't predictions
this is like looking into history and
and already knowing what's going to
happen with mine okay
there's going to be another airline
bailout next year 2022
count on it here's why business travel
kapoot
all right now they somehow weathered it
for one year because you know coveted
shut
everybody down business travelers aren't
coming back maybe they will to a small
percentage but
business travel used to run the airlines
i mean that was the biggest part
number two they got false hope they got
a sugar high
because so many people are spending
their stimulus checks on flying so then
you got that fake thing that you're
thinking that maybe you're coming back
and i saw a lot of people that were
using their stimulus money
to fly i saw that for about five or six
months and leisure travels up right now
airports are crazy you may have seen it
over the weekend but that's gonna die
down too
i mean because people want to get out
there and travel but that's going to
tail off a little at the end of the year
with no business travel with the
stimulus money being gone they're in big
trouble another bailout next year
i think they could be the next newspaper
if they don't
you know how newspapers went from
everybody had a new york times la times
whatever
usa today on the table when you went
into a business yes and now we're all
going online
i think something like that could happen
to the airline industry and someone
today
someone today could disrupt the game in
a massive
way someone could pull it off today i i
don't
i i wholeheartedly agree with you that
something needs to get done you can't
just operate
you know as business as usual like how
it's always been done or else you're
gonna be a dying breed
however there's clearly some airlines
are going to win and some are going to
lose and basically what's going to
happen
is at the end of the day the consumer is
going to lose why because they're just
going to have
less options less flights less
um just
options at the end of the day if two or
three airlines go out of business then
you're just stuck with
american delta united whoever it is uh
and the big winners are gonna
dominate the marketplace just like in
the um the streaming wars how basically
the rich are getting richer and the
bigger getting bigger
the major airlines who are winning this
war will
uh divide and conquer and they'll figure
it out and there's some they're gonna
just
fail like for instance what's the
airline that everyone talks [ __ ] about
what's the one airline that everyone's
like oh those guys
worst customer service well i don't know
what it's called but you know uh spirit
no not
spirit yeah is it spirit yeah yeah yeah
is it airtran i can't hear anybody
spirit's different though because
they're targeting a different audience
you're going low budget you don't expect
high customer service from a low budget
uh airline
where you can't even create a business
spot and the guy's not changing no
exactly and and people are still gonna
fly
you're not coming for customer service
you're coming with shitty
leg room by the way you know what i call
that i call that a business model
exactly that is true that's a different
target there's another one that's
emerging too it's
they're going from these smaller
regional airports the former founder of
jetblue his name is alex wilcox he
started this airline
called jetsuite x if you haven't flown
on jet swedex it probably has it hasn't
come this far east yet but
amazing and there are some smart people
in the airline industry that see
opportunity they're trying to do some
different things
and that that go on service you know i
feel like you're getting threatened
every time you get on the plane
everything you can't do you'll be banned
you'll never be able to fly 35 000 fine
meanwhile you got
you know senorita and and grumpy in the
cabin watching porn
right and doing that so it's a crazy
world in the air
for the industry well don't forget back
in the 80s and
how long roads eventually lead to porn i
think it's just for sure
or the cockpit yeah i mean how many
different airlines
uh merged went out of business
continental
there used to be um multiple different
airlines but it's
so expensive northwest and they merged
when they became part of delta and then
so usa i think usa things are busy
things are going to get consolidated
adam business model has to change what
you're saying is scary to me
let me explain to you why you don't want
that to happen okay why you don't want
that to happen
yes if these companies are screwing up
and you're buying back stocks with the
money that you got on the bailout
yes you the ceo you shouldn't be run the
company period
you should not be run the company while
you're doing that that's a bad decision
you're making that guy needs to get
fired right
but the point with my issue is if we
only have three airlines
guess who's losing the customer customer
loses yeah
you want six seven eight options we win
when there's six seven eight options so
you would much rather have six seven
eight options that are competing
unfortunately right now
i don't see a lot of folks working on
business but like i went on these
flights i'm like okay let me see what
they're going to do differently
nothing i'm like right now this is an
opportunity can i ask you a question
sure
regarding your up-sale idea which is a
great theory and what we've already
talked about the airline history what
about selling porn
in the air they probably make billions
now all of a sudden you're on the porn
side of things
that would need to be session no but
let me let me let me go where he's going
let me go where he's going okay let's
just go where he's going okay
even though i'm not gonna get on that
flight but i guarantee you there's a
model for
you ready okay let's just say an airline
comes out where all the
waitresses or what do you call a flight
attendant are dressed like the girls at
mandalay bay
they're dressed like that looters
waitresses basically let's just say
hooters waitress but i'm talking about
real nice and dressed up real sexy
you know where there's an audience for
it and then on there it's
adults only flight it's truly an adult's
only flight so no kids allowed
it's 18 and up like a resort you know
what's crazy that's a business model
that is a business model what if on a
flight now
airlines try to figure out a way to have
a casino on the flight
that's a business model what if airlines
can now get approval
to have on the flight gambling going on
what if there's a deal what if there's a
poker tournament going on on a flight
what
these are all additional ancillary stuff
that they could where someone's gonna
say dude let me tell you something man
a five hour flight feels like 10 minutes
that's how you would sell it you want to
fly from la to
miami our flights feel like five minutes
why because there's a poker tournament
going on for six hours
and a winner gets a thousand dollars
your flight's taking care of like that's
the kind of stuff that they can do
i'm just telling you there's
entertainment add some spice maybe new
music is a different genre maybe people
like
like italian music you know dean martin
type of music frank sinatra there's a
giant
there's an audience for them maybe it's
an edm flight maybe there's a
i think there's so many the first five
rows being first class and the rest just
being packed in like sardines isn't a
sustainable business model
moving forward just because of the
business model but now that everybody
else is doing it yeah you're screwed
please
differentiate you would have to spend
that flight by the
are you kidding me i'm going to play
poker for you you're not even going to
feel the flight like this you're landing
last thing you know one of the biggest
uh budget items for an airline is
marketing you would have to spend almost
zero on marketing you get so much free
press
i mean literally you'd be getting so
much publicity the garbage monster gave
4.99 says market a mile high club
section
everybody already wants it right yeah
there it is garbage monster you get 10
times uh 10x on your four nine and we
just gave you fifty dollars on uh that
comment that's funny
of course the garbage we have oscar
solis gave 20 bucks and he gave a shout
out to patrick and mario
for answering my message on instagram i
appreciate the efforts in trying to meet
up fluent from chicago to pay respects
to fallen
marine god bless those who serve past
present and future oscar you get ten
times on your twenty dollars
let's send two hundred dollars to oscar
as well for that comment let's continue
okay
that's awesome yeah that's great and by
the way again at the end of it we're
going to go
through uh what do you call it the logos
and if anybody gives super chat
did we pay from last week i have no idea
okay hi sam
dollars we paid all right can i make one
little comment about my grandma
my voice is a little tax today okay and
i think i know why you're yelling at
your wife again
no the other way yeah well i deserve it
she would never deserve to get yelled at
but anyway um i did something so stupid
and i knew i'd pay a price what's that i
hate rides i hate roller coasters
right we went back to minnesota for a
family reunion this week we had a great
time we have seven kids in our family
we grew up on a dirt road of 700 people
seven kids
seven college graduates
yeah so my parents did an amazing job
coming from a small town and we just had
so much fun going back there i hadn't
seen people i didn't see
nieces and nephews i didn't see my
parents in a really long time so we had
a blast
but we were in minneapolis minnesota
we're in minnesota and we went to the
mall of america so we you know just hang
out there it's
one thing you got to do and they have
amusement park in the mall i don't you
know that but
yeah it's really it's a bona fide
amusement park like i'm scared of all
the rides so that way you know it's real
dash talked me into going on one of
these stupid rides i screamed the whole
time
i did i screamed i can't help i can't
open my eyes i hate rides seriously i am
sorry
no no i'm 100 serious i get so scared i
can't believe i went on that ride i
screamed the whole time just begging it
for please tell me somebody record tell
me there's a video to see your face well
my kids will tell you man
if you got a video send it to us dash we
got to turn your dad into a celebrity if
you got the video send it to us well
there's a comment here tom yeah you can
just sit the rest the episode out you
don't need to talk anymore
you found that one didn't you thank you
i actually just made that up however
however i am shocked that a manly man
like you but it's the
true conservative you can't stand up
that just yeah i'm shocked that you
don't
yeah i'd like to have some thumbs up if
you like rides i'm petrified i can't
believe i went on a damn ride
so you're basically saying your 11 year
old son is tougher than you when it
comes to rides
oh god yes pat's under all unborn
conservative ladies and gentlemen tough
guy respect come on
senator dash you are the man i don't
know how many times you have to say this
but that you know you know what i'm
picturing you know what i'm pitching
right now what's that i'm picturing dash
and how i'm sitting there and it's the
old uh oh my god ibrahimovic speech like
bro come on
act like you've been here like you
belong together i deserve a 50 year old
man i'm a 10 year old kid
act like you've been here before bro i
can't do it dash oh man i wish i was
there i i i
i wish i was there to witness what was
dash saying to you giving you laughing
his ass off come on then
then he ripped me called everybody and
said hey this is the funniest thing
because everybody else on the ride
laughs their ass off too they can't
believe what you guys actually don't
know what dash sees this shout out to
dash for being the manly man in the
family one of these days when he's in
town with you tell him we'll bring them
on so people can finally meet
that's who he is so skateboarding okay
all right let's go through this next
exclusive content jeff bezos explosive
explosive content jeff bezos and amazon
now own
all the apprentice outtakes and one
trump
may or may not have said page three oh
my gosh
here we go again this is this is epic
here and who out of everybody would buy
this okay
so explosive content jeff pesos and
amazon now own
all the apprentice outtakes and what
trump may or may not have said this a vt
post story by tom zeno jeff bezos maybe
speak
is seeking to release outtakes from the
apprentice that show its host
former president donald trump making
racist and sexist comments although the
pro-trump and anti-trump
factions aren't likely to change their
stance the amazon purchase of mgm
catalog including the princeton's
apprentice is steering the conversation
stephen colbert
eagerly introduced the idea during the
late show last week why would one of the
world's richest man pay
almost twice the value for a struggling
movie studio and
that recently went bankrupt well it
could be that jeff pesos has an
ongoing feud with the former president
genghis khan he calls trump genghis khan
guess what all the outtakes from the
apprentice are owned by mgm
holy mother of dvd extras the private
footage of a tv billionaire is going to
belong to an
actual billionaire holy meeting
trump's not a god billionaire wow actor
tom arnold fueled the fire in 2018
saying i've seen a compilation tape that
my buddy shared with me he said the n
word he says
he called eric the r word and uh it's
not looking good so what are your
thoughts since you wrote the story
it comes down to this how petty is jeff
bezos i mean does he have bigger things
to worry about than this or would he
actually do something now there
there's some there's some substance to
this as far as what core bear says
because
here's what what did they get for this
purchase he they definitely may have
overpaid for this thing you get the
james bond franchise
which is you know i don't know how big
that is in the long run you get the
rocky franchise
tomb raider real housewives fargo
handmaid's tale jack ryan
but did he do this just to get those
outtakes now number one would anyone
even be surprised i mean if trump said
this
don't we kind of expect this i mean he
survived what he said on access
hollywood with billy bush
two weeks before the election so i don't
think it would matter one way or another
it would give the the left a little
chuckle you know and they would enjoy
seeing this
um but again it just comes down to how
petty he is and
whether he wants to do this and who's in
his ear because
i think bezos doesn't give a crap about
this one way or another i don't i don't
think you can be as successful as jeff
bezos and make emotional decisions that
are stupid
so who's in his ear somebody that has
influence somebody that really wants
them to do it we'll see
and then it comes down to do they even
have the contractual or licensing
agreement to air some of this because
mark burnett
tried to tie a lot of this stuff up so
it couldn't get out there
let me just say this if there's any of
this stuff that exists of trump saying
the n word or the art what's the r word
or [ __ ]
i think so talking about his son that
would be my guess the r word
because they said talking about eric
with the r word okay disrespectful for
your son that's unbelievable yeah
um the r word yeah i guess never go
full r word never do that um but if that
stuff existed
it'd be out there already i don't give a
[ __ ] if bezos bought this
mgm own this if trump if there was
actual footage of trump doing this kind
of stuff as our good friend tom arnold
um alludes to it'd be out there already
are you kidding me you think they're
gonna keep that
buried for five years not a chance and
here's the biggest point here
it says although the pro-trump or the
anti-trump factions aren't likely to
change their stances
the amazon purchased might start the
conversation hell no it ain't starting
the conversation
if there's one thing that trump did is
he drew a line in the sand and said you
were with me or against me
and everyone fell in line how many
people are lukewarm on trump at this
point well you know i'm
i might or might not be in on trump like
he made it very
can you guys see us now or no okay it's
back
do we know what caused that
okay all right sounds good so if we're
back i don't know if you're back just
tell us if you're back or not because
uh is back okay sounds good so so i
think everywhere
yeah so everything that's going on with
this everything that's going on with
this is one thing
why are people paying twice the amount
of money for mgm it's only one reason
there's only one reason why somebody
would do this because everybody believes
trump's gonna run in two years that's
their biggest fear they cannot handle
another four years of trump of calling
them
out every single day look how peaceful
it is right now they can do their side
deals they can do their negotiation they
don't want another trump to be up there
they're so frightened none of this stuff
is going to show up for at least
24 months i see within 24 months all the
stuff that they have on the apprentice
is going to show up and i wouldn't be
surprised if that's that's why i
wouldn't be out there already
no no why would you show it right now
why wouldn't you show it
when j edgar hoover when the mob had
stuff on j
edgar hoover they went up to him and
they just showed it to him they said
look we know who you are
look at these pictures cross-dressing if
you do anything and you say there is
such a thing as a mop we just want to
let you know we're going to show this to
the world
and they never don't care i don't think
trump cares uh i i think if they have
this explosive content yeah
that would not stop him from running i
don't think it would stop him from
running i'm just telling you this stuff
that they're getting i don't know if
it's going to stop them from running
i just think stuff that they're going to
use to you know if you're a professional
forecaster and you've never been wrong
what are the odds trump runs against
this for effect i honestly don't think
trump's going to run again
i really don't and i think this will be
the least of his worries because he can
handle this i think it's the the
indictments that's coming out of new
york i think it's the legal battles that
he's going to be facing the next couple
years
i think at some point he loses interest
i really do i mean he's going to be 75
years old if he's not already
right i still don't think he's going to
run i think i disagree well you know
that's fine but i think there's going to
be other viable candidates on the
republican side
and the power of the republican is going
to try to get desantis or
wherever the momentum is so i you're
asking my opinion i'm just saying
i don't think trump will run do you
think he's going to run or no oh there's
no question about it no questions so if
you're watching this guy's got nothing
else going on if you're watching this
thumbs up he's running thumbs down he's
not running
not running for 21. he's going to be 90
i'm just curious to know what people are
going to say thumbs up he's running
sometimes he's not running i'm looking
at here
on what the okay 421 okay
we're going to get 90 that he's running
all right i guarantee you we'll see what
happened here with that okay let's
continue
uh white house pushes back as memorial
day weekend gas prices top three dollars
for the first time in seven years by the
way
as of right now regular national gas
prices for regular gas
is three dollars and four cents premium
is 364.
diesel is 317. okay that's gas prices
as of right now yesterday i was asking a
bunch of people what gas prices are
where they're at and they were sending
me pictures
calabasas for premium was 4.89 by the
way if you're listening to this
can you post in the comment section how
much gas prices are
where you're at for what kind of gas and
what city you're in i'm just curious so
let's go into that story page six
uh story of gas prices okay so the white
house on friday moved to uh quell
concerns of gasoline price on memorial
day weekend surging about three dollars
per gallon for the first time in seven
years regular gasoline average three or
four
prices which are the highest uh for
memorial day since 2014 were 1.08 more
expensive than a year ago
when demand was depressed due to cover
19 demand destruction coupled with the
price war between russia and saudi
arabia in april 2020 resulted in a crude
oil prices temporarily crushing below
zero
dragging castle gasoline prices but
demand has recently climbed to a
16-month high
as more americans received the vaccine
and stated began states began to reopen
their economies
at the same time supply forward cover
has fallen to a 19-month low
of 23 days while prices have increased
from the low
lows of last year as demand drastically
dipped prices at just about three
dollars a gallon are still well in line
with what they've been in recent decades
said press sector secretary jen
said in a statement that p is silent so
let's just play a game here for a second
here there's going to be a obviously a
large contingency of people they're
going to see inflation
there it is it's the inflation biden
came in everything's inflated that's it
that's the end of the story
so just play a game and just be
open-minded for a second there is
something you don't need to have
a valuetainment economics degree to
understand the laws of supply and demand
right
so when covid hit supply was
very high and demand was very low
right you had saudi arabia and middle
eastern
countries and venezuela everyone pumping
out gas and all of a sudden there was
zero demand because we couldn't go
anywhere and now
demand is back up people are traveling
it's memorial day holiday
you need gas you need gas in your car
you're ready to hit the road you're
about to have a good time
i'm going to minnesota for a family
reunion i got seven siblings i got well
that's a hell of a long drive from
california
you did you needed a lot of gas is my
point so it's a simple case of supply
and demand
now you do hear that inflation is real
and i'm not saying that it's not real
you hear the other argument saying that
it's transitory and it's transient it's
only here for a little while
and time will tell what's going on with
that but i do agree that this is a
supply and demand thing
and as jen saki says she says while
prices have
increased from the lows last year which
is obvious
uh as demand drastically dipped that was
basically march of 2020
price is just about three dollars a
gallon and still well within what
they've been in recent decades which i
agree
now keep in mind i haven't paid for gas
in about 10 years because i don't have a
car
but other than that uh three bucks a
gallon doesn't seem far-fetched
doesn't seem inflationary to me i'd like
to see him change a baby's diaper and
then fill up his car with gas
and just see what kind of mood he's in
and right exactly what's going to happen
first though
the baby would probably be doused in gas
for all we know jesus hey i got to clean
her off a little
okay i'll play along with your supply
and demand thing to a certain degree and
the colonial pipeline
shutdown has something to do with this
on the east coast and that affects
things but
nothing makes people more mad than
watching those numbers go up and up and
up and it costing 75 bucks to fill up
your
your your tesla owners they're laughing
no that's laughing
but you know this can't continue because
a people won't be able to afford it and
b
this really really ticks people off and
it always goes in these ebbs and flows
and it happens and there's these peaks
and then
then somehow it gets leveled off so
let's hope
in the next month this starts to get
leveled off or there's going to be some
real blowback
towards biden because we can't live like
this that's too expensive for gas
especially when you do the things that
biden's doing when you don't want to
have any mining here
in the united states when things that
could alleviate some of this that's so
common sense and then you go this other
route
and it's just too expensive i'll give
them a week or two three bucks a gallon
too expensive
genuine questions well my god i live in
california three bucks would be a treat
so here's let me just give you a price
of what you said 323 regular new york
city subs
suburbs okay okay 283 regular minnesota
costco price in north carolina okay 263
san antonio 349 regular in
washington state 375
in jersey okay 340 in boca raton
349 in vegas up from 229 since biden
took off what's gas here
410 regular 290
410 regular gas in la california 329
chicago suburbs
403 premium in san diego so these are
some different prices
435 for premium in bakersfield says
chris
jolliff okay so pat is any of this
excessive
maybe i'm just being naive no two three
bucks doesn't seem aggressive here's
what i mean that's what you're supposed
to say
meaning the the the audi the party is
going to say
it doesn't seem that excessive it's
right there what do you mean the party
the that's exactly what jen said
jen said i'm just saying for me this
well you're repeating what she said i'm
saying
for me this i stand alone i'm not a
party person here but you're this is
ability saying
you're the three bosses what she just
said
i'm i'm asking you through what she said
i'm saying i don't agree with supply and
demand
you're repeating her words okay let me
read her words while prices have
increased in the low last year as the
man drastically dipped
prices at just about three dollars per
gallon are still well in line
with what they've been in the recent is
that true or not uh i don't i don't
disagree with that but it's gone up
and people are feeling it look i think
that's the biggest thing that people are
upset about
there are sir like i had a conversation
with one of my guys and he calls me this
was like six years ago says pat
i just had a meeting with my guys i
chewed him out because of you know
a terrible month they had last month and
i told them this and i told them
straight away they got to get their act
together i said okay
i said let me let me give you some
perspective on chewing out
when your guys are not doing well
and it's a bad season you lift them up
when they're winning and making more
money than they've ever made you have to
teach them how to stay humble
so the chewing out maybe you bring it
when they become too cocky to arrogant
during when they're winning
at the highest level right okay so today
all right today where we're at
what stephen druckenmiller said to usc's
business school he said i made more
money
in the last 12 months than ever before
he's worth 10 billion
dollars i don't know if we can play it
or not it's on twitter right is it on
twitter so we can play it if it's on
twitter put it up there we'll play this
on twitter
you have to hear what he has to say
you'll see where i'm going with this
because i don't disagree with you
but i'm going to tell you where i'm
going with this guy if you can pull that
up so
this is what you played for us in the in
the meeting yeah we only need to watch
the first minute so here's a guy
that's worth 10 billion that's telling
the world hey
just so you know when they printed all
this money
guess who made the most money you just
made the rich
richer the more money you printed
because the money constantly flows what
to the billionaires so the billionaires
know how to get the money
you just gave them more money the money
didn't flow to the people that needed
the money
the money flowed up the way you put it
in the market because
no it's basically what you're saying is
when a man with experience man with
money meets a man with experience a man
with experience
walks away with the money and a man the
man with the money he works with
experience because what happens what's
that right
what happens if you give of a poor man
money what does he do with them he's
going to spend that [ __ ] to spend it
what happens if he gives you a rich man
who is he's getting invested he's going
to invest it so yeah
it's not the fact that the poor are
getting poorer
because they're not getting the money or
they're not getting handouts
they don't know what to do with the
money this is an educational issue
i want everybody to watch this and it's
going to get to your point that you're
making by the way this man you're
listening to steven drunk
and drunken miller i believe he's worth
10 billion dollars okay play and see
what he says
i'd like to know what he was worth
before the pandemic with the fed in the
inequality i don't think there has been
any
greater engine of inequality
than the federal reserve bank of the
united states the last 11 years
so hearing the chairman talk about
visiting home shelters
homeless shelters is very very rich
indeed
i just had the best year i've had in 15
years last year
everyone wealthy i know is making a
fortune and why are we making it
because this guy is printing money like
there's no tomorrow
and the the kids in harlem
in my opinion are not benefiting from
money printing
but stan druckenmiller and other wealthy
people are so for the life of me
i can't figure out why the left is so
excited
about money printing um when all the
data says
the people that benefit from money
printing are rich people that know how
to
how to navigate what a perspective the
markets so
okay so if you want to listen to the
rest of put the link below if people
want to watch it they can go watch it's
a two minute video i recommend you
watching it
here's what i would say to you adam i'm
not affected if the gas prices go to
twenty dollars a gallon personally
i'm not affected by it i'm 20 i'm not
going to be affected by it because to me
it's just going to be 20 times 20
gallons on my truck 400 bucks i'm fine
with it
i'm not affected by it so this isn't
every time they do these types of things
with gas prices it's like well it's just
the norm here's what's happening
the exact audience that they want to
help is who they hurt
help is the who they heard
so now inflation three bucks you're
right
it's not nothing ridiculous we've had
three bucks in the last decade yes the
highest in the last seven years
the last time it was uh higher than
three dollars was under obama okay
that's when gas prices were higher under
obama's gas prices were higher trump
trump brought it down
biden's bringing it back up democrat
high republican low democrat bringing it
back up again with gas okay
why they sit there and they have good
intentions there's a lot of times in
life like the other day dylan dylan got
hurt he got injured
biking he's a pretty active guy so he's
got scars all over but he's like a
dash type of a guy you saw the scar
split it's not looking good right it's
pretty bad
you saw pretty you saw how hard it was
so i i see it
and the first reaction when senna says
oh my gosh it looks bad to come like
so i come home and i said guys guys guys
i got this kid
i'm going to love on him but this is
something that he's got to realize if
you play sports you're going to have a
lot of injuries he has to know that this
is not the ending of it right
we went through it how much do you think
in that moment i want to love on the guy
kiss him hug him i'm so sorry it's okay
you have no idea how much as a father
you are in pain seeing your kid be in
pain
but that's not what he needs many
policies
we think are the right thing to do
because we feel so bad for people
look noble on the beginning but end up
hurting them
how many decades do we need to go with
the same exact policies until people
finally realize
these policies don't work you're not
going to bail people out of bad habits
rather than doing this teach them better
habits i'm going to make a prediction to
you here's my prediction to you
gas price is 30 bucks okay random
bold prediction don't be surprised if in
the next 12 12 months
gas prices go between five to ten
dollars a gallon let me say that one
more time
do not be surprised if in the next 12
months gas prices go to five to ten
dollars
in the next 12 to 24 months when that
happens
if gas prices go to 725 who takes a hit
wall street no who takes it hollywood
stars
no who takes a hit those who take ubers
you're going to feel it
who takes a hit those who go and buy the
milk at the market for 3.99
now you're going to pay for 4.99 because
whoever's delivering that has to what
that cost has to be counted on for the
delivery of the equipment
who's going to feel it amazon price is
going to go up whole food price is going
to go up
you know kroger price is going to go up
regular day-to-day stuff you buy is
going to go up
inflation is coming there's no way they
can fight manipulating the market for
this long having interest rates being
loaned and one percent for a while they
are begging behind closers finding the
most manipulative ways to keep inflation
down
but it's at a point right now that you
can't do nothing about it 12 to 24
months when gas price remember write
this date down kai in your notes
so we know which podcast to go to to cut
the short clip it's podcast episode
number
65 and today's dates is what june 1st i
want you to write down notes when i ask
you we're going to come to this
gas prices are going to go five to ten
dollars within the next 12 to 24 months
and you know who takes the biggest hit
low income middle-income family not wall
street who well true
but that'll be one of the biggest crisis
this country's faced if gas prices go up
to oh
you'll see i mean there'll be an
absolute river that's venezuela i mean
literally what's going on
there yet but but but we're getting to a
point where again
low income middle income is going to pay
the price
and every time these folks keep keep
giving
money out thinking it's the right thing
to do you're hurting these guys
my kids ask me a question dad can we get
can we get paid to
read a book no can we get paid because i
ate my food
no the other day the kids are getting
ice cream i come home like mama why is
the kids getting
oh because they ate good food let me get
this straight i said they got ice cream
because they ate their food yeah
since when do we give kids ice cream i'm
sorry dad my dad's sitting right there
i said dad did you give us ice cream
when we ate our food i said we got ice
cream once a month
i said i'm sorry babe how many times did
you get ice cream so we never got ice
cream
i said mama what is the system with kids
get ice cream because they ate their
food you're supposed to
so i brought the kids and i said what is
your ex i said so this is the ice cream
so oh
i can't stop them from getting the ice
cream it's in the freezer i said oh
really
so i now cannot buy ice cream because
the ice cream sits in the freezers and
kids can come and take it
so i grab the ice cream i bring it out i
said kids come here we're gonna have a
conversation together do you want to
trust yes
i said i'm gonna trash these ice creams
right now if you tell me
you are going to go out and take the ice
cream without asking permission i'm
trashing all of these
do you want to develop trust with me i
do daddy malva if you
cannot lead these guys without eating
guys or just because they ate their food
i'm going to trash you so what do you
guys want to do no no no moving forward
no problem
you don't get ice cream for eating your
food america right now with the policies
we're just giving ice cream
to kids because they ate their food
you're supposed to eat your
thank god you have food to eat we're
giving people rather than saying
let's go create jobs let's go get a job
how about these 10 million renters
how about these 10 million renters right
now that the bailout for renting is
coming up in 30 days yeah
10 million okay what are they going to
be doing we've been paying their rent
for 10
do you know what a catastrophic issue
that is if we can no longer bail these
guys out
for how many months have they not been
paying 15. can you tell us about this 10
million because you wrote about it
yes so that's coming um so the
moratorium on
you know not being able to evict people
is going to end
it's ending and when is it july 1st so
you know
that these landlords will do it
immediately they're pissed off i mean
they haven't been getting paid
you know it's caused a lot of hardship
for people that own these businesses as
well so
it's a real deal and it's gonna
adversely affect the african-american
community i mean it's right there in the
story the whole thing so
um yeah because the left they can only
think day-to-day they only think about
you know making people like them for one
more day and to keep them acceptable and
keep them in office they're not they
don't care about any long-term
solutions or using any any real you know
strategy to fix this stuff but that's
coming and if
i know landlords and i know renters and
it's going to be affecting them
i mean this is important to read it's a
lifetime thrown to 10 million plus
struggling renters in the u.s has only
30 days to run
and many of the americans face eviction
the center for disease control and
prevention helped to establish an
eviction
moratorium that began last september and
provide assistance in the wake up
pandemic
today with reports indicating millions
are behind on their payments
there's real danger coming as the june
30th deadline approaches
by the way this is real you you really
want to see protesting
raise gas prices you really want to see
protesting give people free rent for
months and all of a sudden tell them
it's gonna go away
watch the real kind of protest you're
gonna see and then what are you gonna do
like you said
next year what's coming another stimulus
another stimulus and then all of a
sudden we're sitting there saying
we have taught the american people in
the last four years we can send the
money
we can send the money and then gas
prices go to 10 bucks then they're gonna
say
how can you raise gas prices ten bucks
you asked for it
you asked for it yeah this is what took
place and this is gonna i mean this is
if you really think about the impact of
this because covent and everything just
it gave you this sense this false sense
of security like you're going to get
these stimulus checks things are going
to be taken care of but this is real
there's going to be people on the
streets here
in 30 days which is the last thing this
country needs is more homeless
adam thoughts no that's it's going to be
a major issue
i i and my prediction is that they're
going to extend the moratorium past
june 30th god how much longer can they i
agree i agree i think
uh i think at the end of the day
september is going to be
the de facto date where all this is
going to come to an end because kids got
to go back to school
life has to go back to normal uh you
might want to give people a heads up
not that there isn't a heads up already
30 days and i'm sure if you're getting
your rent paid for you're
very closely tracking this story but at
the end of the day i wholeheartedly
agree with you we can't just keep
printing money like this it's absurd
and giving people ice cream because they
ate their food
is a very good analogy right here and i
agree with you watch this how much you
love uber
um i these days it's uh i do
i'd like uber more than lyft i used to
be a lift you know what i mean by that
i'm just saying that model look dude
not the name forget about uber or yeah
it's fantastic okay
okay so for you you have money you you
you're you're great out there okay
you're an expert you don't wake up in
the morning stressed out about money
you're very disciplined you are somebody
that
has your own show sauce talks money and
people uh by the way your episode
yesterday that came i got a lot of love
on the commentary they're loving what
you're talking about
thank you by attending economics but you
have you are teaching the basic
fundamentals of what it takes to create
good habits that eventually could
help you get out of debt right correct
you didn't come out of wealth you didn't
come out of family
you you had a family that passed we got
a two million dollar check that did not
happen to you you just stayed
disciplined over the years
are those basic fundamentals that you
teach transferable to anybody else
oh 100 percent who can we teach those
basic fundamentals that you teach
everyone on amazon
can anybody learn it now yes here's a
question for you what percentage of
america do you think
actually applies what you're talking
about well the stats show that 75
percent of americans live paycheck to
paycheck okay so
the odds aren't good so let me ask this
question why isn't the government
focusing on education why why like
here's an idea for you what about the
white house's
youtube channel the white house's
youtube channel forget about all this
prageru what if the white house's
youtube channel
creates content for a year straight
all having to do with educating them on
how money works
what if you're i love that what if the
approach became
let's educate the basics of money what
if the approach became
let's educate you on the tax pro why we
benefit entrepreneurs
what if the approach became how to
become better parents
how to become better adults how to
become better innovative what if we
taught the basics
what if they think the responsibility of
the school system needs to be changed
and that's
i think well i get that but all i'm
saying is we look up to these folks at
the top
okay we look up to these people that are
running for office or they're governors
or senators or congressmen or presidents
they have such a massive influence that
they can make that even their business
by the way
you know how we talk about america like
the airline industry needs to have a new
business model like their business model
no longer works
america's political systems business
model
also needs a little bit of revamping i
agree it's also needing
to read blue ocean strategy they also
kind of need to sit there and say what
the hell are we up to yeah what are we
doing here you know the scary thing
if you even making that suggestion we
laugh at it because we know they would
never do that the white house
and creating that type of content
because it would go against everything
that they're trying to do
and everything that keeps them in power
right i mean the last thing they want to
do is empower people to maybe
do better on your own you know not
depend on the government more that's
that's their business model and that's
the time
how much longer until a youtuber becomes
a president
um our lifetime probably okay i agree i
agree um by the way this is not i'm not
uh saying i'm gonna go wrong i'm not
born here so a lot of people that say
pat want you to run
not born here i'm not interested in
governorship but how much long control
youtuber runs
for office i think it's gonna happen
next 20 30 40 years
and what if a youtuber is a president
and
this youtuber decides to use white
house's youtube channel
for an approach of education what if
somebody becomes a president and they
actually document what the president
does on a daily basis and we follow the
president's journey
the daily vlog what if we actually went
what if a
youtuber comes out and says my
campaign's going to be the following
transparency and here's how we're going
to do it look there's certain things i
can't bring you on the inside
because i cannot have our enemy see what
we're doing but pretty much everything
else that i can
i want to show you what my day looks
like i want to show you what time i wake
up i want to show you what the things i
deal with
family kits i just want you to see what
we're going through here and i'm
comfortable with it
what if a youtuber takes that approach
so i think it's eventually going to
happen in the next 20 30 40 years
and when somebody does that they're
going to be known as an innovative
president they're going to change the
game
but it's going to be a 20 year old right
now that's watching this or listening to
this
a 30 year old that's sitting around
saying i think i can do something about
it and by 50 years old they're going to
be able to do something like that sure
and
if an influencer becomes president
they're for sure going to do that
because that's what would have got them
elected
well i actually think you have your your
spot on right here pat
about that i think you know it's funny
because
a youtuber might become president that's
just a famous person at this point
before yeah you mean celebrities like
the the
how long ago were the a-list celebrities
just hollywood hollywood only
you've got youtubers the the paul
brothers as an example who are the
biggest names in social media and media
logan's gonna have legs okay i know
you're a big believer in logan jake he's
a little more of a trashier version of
logan
but i know you're a big believer in that
guy that guy's just famous at this point
is this
isn't youtube famous people the fight's
coming up are you going to go it's it's
this weekend it's this weekend you might
not logan paul floyd mayweather
i'm not i'm not i'm watching it though
i'm buying that thing for sure who are
you rooting for
logan paul for chaos i just want chaos
that's all i don't care who wins i mean
you don't care who wins at all yeah i
mean it's obvious who's going to win but
what do you mean it's obvious this was
going to work who's going to win you're
talking about
the greatest defender of all time what
are you talking about it's the greatest
time so you think he's the greatest
defender of all time
you don't think you don't think logan
paul is going to touch him there's no
way you can get close to that guy he's
the greatest defender of all time you
know how many tricks to the game he
knows
yes he knows all the true you think a
guy is going to come just because he's
training with
you know the king grind guy the guy that
i reingard say i love that guy i love
what he's doing
it's just not going to happen by the way
guys like that have legs long term
a ryan garcia has legs long term a logan
paul has
legs long term those types of guys have
legs long term to do something hey
justin bieber has legs long term
to do something i'm telling you guys
right now you know to play along with
that
the point you made a few minutes ago
money versus experience yeah i mean
that's what we're going to see on that
floor on that ring
because you do realize at any second of
that fight floyd could end it if he
wants to
logan drops his gloves for one hand he
makes for one second he makes one
mistake he turns the wrong way
it's done i think he's probably going to
go easy on him and not kill him but
it'll be a boring fight because that's
how floyd
yeah of course i'd like to see logan
paul win really are you kidding me who
wouldn't want to see logan paul win
well a lot of people they get a lot of
haters no no i'd love to see logan paul
win it's
under the i'm the underdog community i'd
love to see logan here's a prediction
i think jake paul is going to upstage
the event somehow he's going to do
something where he becomes the bigger
story after this fight
listen whatever anybody is saying you're
going to have to put up with the paul
brothers for the next 50 years
period i think logan for sure i don't
know
uh jake's you're gonna have to figure it
out if he's alive in five times that's
the challenge that's gonna be i'm not
even joking that guy's the kind of guy
that crash would burn
really i don't i don't uh i don't think
you're joking and you saw that he just
announced that he's gonna be fighting
uh the trainer to
who's the guy that he just beat ben uh
axel
ben askren yeah his trainer so
in my opinion that guy's got to fight a
real boxing guy let's talk about your
story let's talk about the biden story
in china
the one you liked here as well page five
i'm gonna do both of them at the same
time so if you want to go to page five
uh this is adam's story that he wants us
to cover which is a great story so biden
wants the second one is biden wants to
make
moving to the u.s from abroad easier and
cheaper by revamping the
immigration system there's a business
inside insider story
by the administration plans to rebuild
and expand the u.s legal immigration
system according to 46-page government
documents seen at the new york times dhs
plans to restore trust
in our legal immigration system to draft
documents outline plans to undo
president trump's effort to make
immigration more difficult expensive and
slower
policies described in document would
help more people move to the u.s
including refugees asylum seekers
traffic and victims skilled workers
families of americans living aboard
abroad
and native americans born in canada the
administration administration plans to
rebound various programs and immigration
systems including h1b1 visa program
for highly skilled workers uh in the u.s
visa program work until
documentary so what do you think about
this what do you think about this i
think making it easier
i think part of the problem and
i think part of the problem that trump
ran into was i know people are going to
say
he wanted legal immigration he wanted
legal immigration he wanted to build a
beautiful wall
with a big beautiful door and that's
great and that's all good
but he under the underbelly the
undertone was that he was sort of
anti-immigrant so that was what a lot of
people were offended by
what i think i'm look
we need to welcome immigrants in this
country immigrants are who make
america you're an immigrant okay my my
grandparents were immigrants from russia
yeah
russian ashkenazi jews that came over
here had nothing and made a
you know a living and made a life and
and i think the biggest thing who what
did reagan his most famous quote is we
want to be a shining city on a hill and
a beacon of hope
for the world i think that's where
america has lost his stature under trump
there was a
lot of good things that happened under
trump this isn't a trump hater
uh are you are you saying stats or are
you spitting out
lines i'm saying stats or lines i'm just
saying this is my opinion here
i think number one we need to stats
disagree with you okay
well let me just tell me why go ahead no
i think show that obama deported more
people
than any other president in history of
america to mexico that's that's
that's that's a bit i'm talking
immigration overall
but no overall but immigration overall
the main issue
was from the mexican border we don't
have issues with people coming here from
you know iran or china or you know
italy there's a lot of people coming and
not leaving yeah yeah we don't have a
problem with that the problem why people
said uh trump was anti-immigration was
only one country
and it's not one south or central
america that was the problem so when
you're talking about immigration
if you talk stats that's favor against
he did talk about [ __ ] countries and
having people i know countries you can't
dispute
this isn't turning into a trump thing
this is more of a commentary on
immigrants
immigrants should be welcome to america
yes we want people that work hard
that pay their dues that want to make
something of themselves
but you can't beggars can't be true it's
kind of a thing people are go
we we want people to come to america and
there's some money behind this
tax revenue we do have social security
to pay for it baby boomers are getting
older
we need young people able bodies to be
working in america paying taxes that's
what we do
no one disagrees with america there's a
lot of welcomed immigrants there's a lot
of people that do disagree i don't think
so there's a lot of antibiotics
there's a poll out there kai you might
want to pull this off it's stats
it does give me stats i'm polls this is
a stat
that's not a stat that's a poll opinion
that's opinion okay
a poll is an opinion i'm asking stats if
you give stats
no one deported more people than obama
again i'm not trying to get political
here i'm talking about that
pro-immigration i get that so if i read
this article your business insider okay
look how they
read it look how they write this article
you can tell
which way they lean just by the way they
wrote it policies described in the
document would help
more people move to the u.s including
refugees
asylum seekers trafficking victims
skilled workers
family of americans living abroad and
native americans born in canada
now if this was an article written about
trump you know what that would say
he uh trump policies described in
document would force
families to split up with force the way
they're writing it as if it's like an
angel uh biden is doing the greatest
thing look we know what's happening here
you want more votes it's exactly what
they want pelosi said i've always done
we should make votes at 16 years old you
want a 16 year old voting hey we should
get more people that are immigrants
undocumented people
to vote of course that's all political
this is a political plan and biden won't
even address the fact that there is an
issue going on in the southern border so
i think you lose a lot of credibility
when you're talking about immigration
when you can't fix a pretty major
problem that we have going on right now
in this country
so the credibility is shot and people
welcome immigrants we've always done
that and i don't think immigrants care
about being welcome they just want the
opportunity to come here and be able to
work and do their thing
that's all they're looking for so look
you can't trust them
i mean it's a complete mess with what's
going on down there you know what i
would say about this guys
here's the following okay so to the to
the person that
is 43 years old has been living in u.s
for 25 years
parents came here and they've been here
for 25 years they're americans they've
lived in america more than they lived in
mexico
what are we waiting for with legalizing
these people what do we do we're talking
about the dreamers
yeah wholeheartedly what are we doing
thank you for saying that what are we
doing like what what are you doing like
the
this is this is this has been part of
the these kids didn't do anything wrong
they were under 18 when their parents
came here
yeah you want to say daca i don't
understand that concept and why
republicans won't agree to that i
i don't by the way obama had a chance to
do it nothing happened
what do you mean because the republicans
voted against it but but you mean to
tell me the last four years democrats
and republicans whoever is in charge
should make it happen this is not a
republican or democrat oh it is though
i okay the democrats are the ones
proposing i'll say 60
is the republicans holding back 40 is
democrats i'm gonna say 60
republicans 40 democrats they've had
both both house and the senate to be
able to pull this up how come you
haven't done it
how come you haven't done it half the
time why [ __ ] doesn't get done is
because they over negotiate
when you over negotiate you go into
gridlock when you go into gridlock
nothing gets done
that's half the challenge that they got
you ask 75 different things that you put
in there
and the other part is like listen i'm
not doing this you're trying to pull in
minimum wage by 2025. i'm not agreeing
to this so these are the types of things
yeah they're trying to sneak [ __ ] in
there
but but to me dude you've been living
here for 25 years you're not one you
don't want to make this person legal
how much taxes has this person paid
sales how much tax does this person
let's just already flip that what now at
the same time you got a
criminal record hey felony you got all
that stuff i'm sorry different story
we have to figure that part out a clean
house as well but for that community
i don't i don't know and also here's
something
and i actually think trump was actually
pro this so this is this is actually me
giving trump credit
this h-1b visa program yeah these are
highly skilled workers these are some
are we losing them
why would the hell would you want
someone who comes over here from
india from south korea pick a country
goes to university learns to become an
engineer and then after after they
graduate you send them back
the only ones i would be very concerned
about the only ones and i'm being that
serious with you the only ones i would
be very concerned about
our uh uh donation from china no china
from china and a bit of iran by the way
and yeah and i'm from iran
yeah i would be very concerned i would
do additional
uh uh due diligence to see where it's
coming from you know what's crazy
did you watch that video kai sent two
nights ago or last night about africa
did you see that basically bought africa
china basically bought africa they built
a the african union headquarters
with 300 million dollars and later on in
the middle of the night every night
they're like why is our system down
china was getting all the emails all the
data the employees
every office was wiretapped and they're
listening what africa is up to
what is their strategy man they they
they own it and
they pay for all their infrastructure
right they and that's a good segue into
the next story
the craziest part of that video though
was with the furniture and how
like in the furniture there's wires and
there's bugs
made custom into the furniture like how
crazy does that
i would be very very careful with
china and which family it's coming from
that would be me my own and it's
unfortunate to say this
in which family i i want to do more due
diligence of what your background is as
you're coming here i want to know where
you're coming from i want to know what
what you're most
when you're coming to america that's the
only thing i'm i'm a little bit
concerned with that part but aside from
that i mean i get it
you know i get the fact that uh when
talent comes here you go to our school
we train you and we send you back what
are we doing here
let's make sure yeah let's keep you keep
talent here yeah keep talents here so
that's
smart no question about it let's go to
the next story
bold plans joe biden says china's goal
to
own america before 2035 vt post story
president biden during the speech to
american service members in virginia
said chinese leadership thinks it will
own america before 2035. we're in a
battle between
democracies and auto uh uh uh uh
uh okay we saw biden told troops at
joint base
langley eustis in hampton the more
complicated the world becomes the more
difficult it is for democracies to come
together and reach consensus
i've spent more time with president xi
of china than any other world dealer
leader has for 24 hours of private
meetings with him
just with just an interpreter 17 000
miles traveling with him in china and
here
he firmly believes that china before the
year 2035 is going to own america
because
autocracies can make quick decisions
biden said the us's political landscape
has never been more divided and that
appears to be among the reasons biden
believes china
could think it has an ownership opening
got a real problem with this um and he
also brags about the fact that no
leader from america spent more time with
the chinese president that they traveled
together for 17
000 miles with and then they were
together for 24 hours with just an
interpreter and they're discussing these
things
why are you telling us this in the
fashion that you are why aren't you more
like um
china thinks they're going to own us but
i'm telling you right now i will not let
that happen
it's not going to happen on my watch i
didn't get that from him saying this
um i would just china is clearly
has a strategy to do this part of the
problem that there's this division that
he talks about
is because of biden and i would just
like to hear something from him saying
yeah we know what you're up to and we've
got a counter plan to make sure that
doesn't happen
like he just made it seem like fact as
opposed to this is a huge problem
if china thinks they're going to own us
and we're not going to allow it to
happen how come this isn't a huge
like issue for him a little too cavalier
for me
i think it is i think you're just
reading the the headline and and
just making an assumption he's basically
saying we need to do something about
china i think the biggest fear
when biden came into office with people
saying well he's not going to be tough
on china and
that was all trump biden is basically
saying look i'm going to pick up where
trump left off
okay he's been like what's my favorite
show that i watch every sunday it's
fareed zakaria
and he's a very smart guy and he
basically said in a world where
americans
are so divided the one issue that we all
agree on is the threat that china is
imposing
okay and he went off for five minutes on
the threat that china's imposing and
this guy is a
liberal uh very smart guy on cnn and
just went
off on the fears of china so
it's very easy to say well the right uh
is doing everything against china and
the left isn't
that's just not true okay plus look at
what's going on in the world you said
the biggest
threat to china potentially if the world
coalesces and actually fights china
so you have india you have australia you
have japan you have
all the countries in the south china sea
that are basically saying oh the eu
keep in mind enough's enough uh let's
get to the bottom what the hell china is
up to so
i think in theory uh saying that biden
isn't doing enough or the world isn't
doing enough
is great to say it's great for headlines
but i think in actuality
people understand that china is a major
threat yeah i don't i don't know if i
buy that and
and here's here's how i see that um is
it fair to say that hunter has had some
dealings with china yes
yes it's public right now he writes
about it people talk about it it's
public it's nothing that anybody is
fighting that there's not
uh any issues there is it fair to say
that
hunter had some bad uh habits
and addictions yes that maybe when
you're
addicted to a drug you tend to make
stupid decisions is that a fair
assessment when you're on crack read his
book
right you make bad decisions he talks
about it openly do you agree with that
when you're on drugs you make bad
decisions yeah but
okay where are you going i'm gonna go
stay with me here is it fair to say that
if you're dealing with folks
in china and you like drugs and the
enemy knows
what you like they know how to persuade
you and then they know how to get
information from you
which means in a situation like this do
you think china has intel on hunter that
we don't know about
do you i don't know i think for me if
i'm a betting man i'm going to say 10
the answer is yes i think china has some
stuff on hunter
which means any conversation they have
with joe it's going to be based around
hunter the whole story with j edgar
hoover when the mob met went with them
and they said hey
just so you know the next time you act
tough here's what we have of you i have
a feeling there was a moment where she
said let's walk out over here and i want
to talk to you by ourselves
here's what we have moving forward
here's what your script is this is what
you can say
and here's what you can't say and if you
don't it's not going to be nice for you
i just want you to know this if he
didn't say it somebody may have told him
that
maybe completely wrong i may be
completely over speculating that's why i
said 10
credence i'm given to this what upsets
me the most about this is the following
um there's a story about facebook
ending bans on post asserting covet 19
was man-made the story came about last
week it's a wall street journal story
facebook has ended its ban on post
asserting covet 19 was man-made or
manufactured a policy shift that
reflects a deepening debate
over the origins of the pandemic that
was first identified in wuhan china
about 18 months ago
president biden on wednesday ordered the
u.s intelligence inquiry
into the origins of the virus the white
house has come under pressure to conduct
its own investigation after china
after china told the world health
organization that it considered
uh beijing part of the investigation
complete calling for efforts to trace
the viruses origins to shift into other
countries
let me read this one more time folks i
want you to list i'm going to read it
slower
the white house this is a wall street
journal article this is not us writing
it
this is wall street journal the white
house has come under pressure
to conduct its own investigation after
china
told world health organization that it
considered beijing's
part of the investigation complete let
me get this straight i'ma read it one
more time
white house has come under a lot of
pressure to conduct its own
investigation because china told
world health organization that it
considered beijing's part of
investigation completely like listen
we checked on it already don't worry
about it it's okay america
nothing really happened you don't need
to do anything calling for efforts to
trace the viruses
origins to shift into other countries
earlier this month a group of 18
prominent scientists called for a deeper
investigation into the circumstances in
which the virus emerged
including the possibility that a
laboratory accident released it facebook
and february began to ban on claims the
virus was man-made or manufactured as
part of his list of misleading health
claims
that aren't allowed so so here's here's
my problem with this here's my problem
with this
look uh it's march
of 2020. we find out this virus is
i think the first person died and the
you know the shutdowns was taking place
you know disneyland all this other stuff
that was taking place
trump goes and travels flights from
china
what does uh biden call racist
xenophobic
racist what does nancy pelosi do she
goes to chinatown
and says look these are good people and
he says wait a minute what are you
talking about i'm banning this because
it could be man-made
the moment anybody on the right said
they released the virus you know what
they call those people
conspiracy theorists the word conspiracy
theorists the moment somebody tags the
conspiracy theorist on you
what happens to you you lose credibility
you know what's crazy
the whole scandal with russia for three
years that was the ultimate conspiracy
theory
ever there's never been a bigger hoax
than the russia
scandal the dossier that clinton's paid
35 million
there's never been a bigger scandal than
that that was a scandal
the moment it came out that it was a
scandal and was a conspiracy theory
the ma the media stopped talking it was
just kind of like oh the russia
scandal's not real
okay but let's talk about this year
because wait wait wait wait no no no no
three years you've been talking about
this address this no no no no no we're
moving on we have to go
no no you just talk okay so they are
there's so much hypocrisy there because
a year ago
the democrats had only one plan and
here's what the plans were
and as a registered independent who
thinks bill clinton
was a decent president who thinks me who
thinks bill clinton was a decent
president he was able to get things done
with newt gingrich
me uh first president i shook hands with
was bill clinton
the independent guy here is sitting here
saying a year and a half ago you
silenced anybody that said it could be
man-made
because in your mind you only had one
thing in mind
we have to figure out a way to blame
covet on somebody
who do we blame covet on one person
if we do china the guy gets reelected
because it brings the entire country
together
you know who we have to blame we blame
trump because if we blame trump
we win the election everybody went off
of russia story
they went into the china story trump's
fault they put all the pressure and
default on trump
and what does trump do here's what trump
does he gets elected a week later
vaccine comes out he loses the election
a week later vaccine comes out who did
that
but fauci said it's going to take 18
months to have vaccines oh i'm sorry
fauci brought the pressure no trump
brought the pressure the handling of
kovit
may have been one of the greatest
handlings of a pandemic a president has
done
without any training on it no one's been
talking about
training on this for a long time no
one's gone through it
no one's gone through it at this level
we're like oh here's what we gotta be
doing
this guy handles it well he handles in
the right way
they divide they pin it on him after he
loses
five months later all of these guys have
a conference call and now they want to
say
could be manmade and facebook removes
how many billions of views of people who
had opposing arguments about this being
man-made was taken down
how many doctors who did an interview
with abc talking about hey
this virus how many of those interviews
were banned remember that whole
african-american
african doctor that went up there and
she talked about it she got like
hundreds of millions of views taken down
the doctor from bakersfield taken down
why because it's an opposing view i'm
sorry so what is a conspiracy theory
what percentage of conspiracy theories
are right this whole alien thing was a
conspiracy theory
everybody's not talking about aliens
this whole jfk thing was a conspiracy
theory everybody's talking about jfk
assassination
all of these things you call the
conspiracy theory guess what they just
did
as a person who's a hardcore skeptical
guy myself
as a person who's hardcore skeptical you
know what this whole nonsense about
facebook saying we end
ban on post asserting kova 19 was
man-made you know who won
here's who won conspiracy theorists one
they won you now have to sit there and
say i'm sorry
these conspiracy theories weren't
conspiracies maybe there was some weight
behind it
it's not okay to do that look
charlemagne god calls out kwame brown
hardcore okay talks about his family and
all this other stuff
you know what charlemagne did here's
what charlemagne did he got up then he
gave an apology
beautiful apology i listened to the
whole thing this morning in six minutes
hats off to charlemagne uh media
are we getting an apology facebook the
judy mike of its interview that was
taken down
the the virologist that was taken down
all the opposing stories that were taken
down are we are you
are you going to give any credit to what
happened to the last administration or
is this is china is the kova still
trump's fault is that what it is
oh now it's china's fault here's the
biggest opportunity we missed on this
this is what upsets me the most and i'm
going to wrap up because we got five i'm
gonna hear your thoughts and we'll wrap
up we may not even get a chance to go
into the what do you call it the
logos because we got the other thing
adam here's what upsets me
the most um we had such an
opportunity last year for america to be
united man
we had such a big opportunity last year
to be
united 911 united us
we had such a big opportunity to get
united last year we missed the mark
who caused it partly trump because you
wouldn't uh uh
uh prevent what he can be in the whole
divisive like the last two presidents
prior to biden development device of
obama was the device if he was the vice
constant dividing and then the left the
media everybody we had such a
beautiful opportunity last year for
america to come out being stronger but
we came more divided
we missed a massive opportunity because
we could have shared one common enemy
and it would have been who china but you
know why we couldn't have done that
because if
last year we would have said china trump
in trump would have been reelected you
know and that's one way of looking at it
and a lot of people do the the democrats
were so obsessed with trump and their
only objective was to get him out
russia didn't work i mean they tried
like hell to have that work it didn't
they had
no this is people's theories now the
other thing the byproduct of what they
did is they knew if the economy would
tank
that would be another big role in trump
not winning and that was another
byproduct of this whole thing and and
the saddest thing about it in my opinion
is we did miss an opportunity to become
united and have this
be something that can draw the country
together but there's certain factions
that just don't want that
and the the mainstream media is one of
them unfortunately that's not good for
their business and it's not good for
their model
so you're not going to get those types
of stories or the truth
in some cases where that's going to you
know happen where the country's going to
be united and as a matter of fact
they're going to go the opposite
direction very very hard
i'd like to see where facebook goes from
here because if they're basically saying
we're ending the ban
um are they going to give some reasoning
some justification
like what's the what's the story i don't
they don't have to do that the guy who
went on james o'keefe and who was a
former facebook employee and he uh
said all the stuff that he said facebook
fired him the next day and said sue us
do whatever you want to do
do what you got to do well i think the
silver lining here and i do agree with
you
that whether it was the media whether it
was trump whether it was
cove whatever it is everything has
gotten so politicized
and we are as divided as ever i i would
love to see
the country rally and unify against a
common threat or common enemy of china
and um as as someone who gets the label
of the resident leftist here
uh i can tell you that uh we are equally
concerned with china
and about time adam i would say about
time because about a year ago you were
not
uh you're upset with me that it took me
a while to
come around no no no no my my my
frustration is the fact that
many smart individuals like you mr mark
my my and by the way we all go through
this at some point in our lives you're
not the only one
you know what you know what the biggest
challenges is those this is the problem
adam if i give you the problem this is
the problem
you know how you're like here's here's
what's starting to happen in america
which is actually not a bad thing
the problem is when republicans see
a thing sean hannity says and they're
like i don't know if i agree with that
but i have to because i'm a republican
right you know uh anderson you know i
don't know if i agree with that
[ __ ] i'm a democrat yeah i agree with
that you know
i don't know if i i agree with that you
know that whole thing
that's what everybody went through last
12 18 months
everybody's longer than that yeah no but
but but yes you're right it was because
of trump
uh let me just remind you real quick i
was a registered independent
full-on my entire life never voted for
republican president so
that's but i was a clinton guy but
what's your point
but you say that as if like you are like
well you've probably never voted for it
yeah
but of course of course i have you
didn't vote for clinton
what year what are you talking about you
voted for clinton what are you talking
about
my point is this here's my point i was a
registered independent
yeah and then when trump showed up i
became a democrat okay
so now that he's gone it's a lot
easier to be an independent thinker this
was trump's
gift and curse you're either with him or
you're with him against him
and for someone who was against him he
could but
you you you were against him emotionally
yes
whether
if you would have seen the policies
there was no palestine israel issue
there was no isis issue there was no gas
issue there was no economy issue
there was no wars there was none of that
there was fake russia which was fake
you know was fake yourself we've talked
about this that was the ultimate
conspiracy theory where for three years
all we heard about is the fact that this
guy's got a dealing with russia
and he's got he's on the inside with
putin it's all we heard none of it was
true
what happened kovit came best crisis for
the left they used it they kicked him
out
and boom he's out now we're dealing with
all this other stuff that's going on
today
so that part yeah i have a problem with
that and uh
yes i'm glad finally many people are
finally realizing the real enemy
the last 18 months has not been trump
the real enemy the last 18 months has
been
one country and it's china and now you
want to say you couldn't say last year
because you had to blame trump on it
last year
you're finally figuring out this you're
not you you being biden in the camp on
the other side that's saying
and you voted yeah there's also 86
million people that voted so to label
people
blind or yeah i think they are i
actually do believe
i do believe majority were blind because
we didn't because the main
what is the main main method of where
majority of people get their information
two places what are they media and
social media media and social media both
are controlled on one side
yes you're right both are controlled on
one side hollywood one side
sports all all this most of the sports
commentators what side are they on
left yeah what side are they on namely
one right guy that's a big name
in sports he won't have a giant troy
troy aikman is a football guy yeah okay
he's a commentator who else outside of
troy
you are joe buck who else joe buck who
else give me anybody from espn that
stays there
anybody from espn that keeps smith oh
really the guy's on the left who else
do you think stephanie smith is another
hundred percent he's on the left adam
adam are you kidding me funny you're so
we've talked about where anything
steven a smith trump yeah i think he's i
think he's a center left guy but he's on
the left oh i thought you thought he was
on the right
i think he's a center left who if you
talked about his real values that his
mom taught him he'd be a center right
but he can't i'm good with anybody who's
center left or center right
the problem i have are the leftists or
the complete
right autocrats out there that's my
biggest problem
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're center
left i don't give a [ __ ] if your center
right
what i what i don't like is if you're
too far left or too far right
i wish and that's where that's basically
where we're at i wish we had more time
with you folks could this is when it was
starting to get juicy if you enjoyed
today's podcast smash that
subscribe button and the notification
button and any of the short clips that's
going to come up later on today if kai
is able to get them to us
we'll share it with you a couple of them
i think are worth sharing with others
and if you are not getting the
notification when the podcast go up do
me a favor and subscribe to our text
messages that we send out
that's in the us 310-340-1132
send a text message to that number we
will get you on our text list as well
gank phenomenal uh commentary adam tom
good stuff
i think again the only people that want
today is the audience that's the goal
thanks everybody take care bye bye bye
you